[Music]
hello everyone and welcome,
so do you speak the cloud, I'm
Étienne guerin slap consultants based
at google paris and in this episode we
're going to talk about instanz
drops manades see what their usefulness is and
find out how they can be used
in  the fantastic knitting architecture
in the previous episodes
we saw together how we
can easily move
applications to google cloud
you probably remember that we
had an architecture with only
two web servers
it's a good start but if the knitting has
much more successful than expected
a bit like pokemon go how to do
in this episode we will see
together how to make the
lamp application even more negative claude
i.e. scalable and
automatable scalability consists in making
the application capable of  cope with an
increasing internet traffic load
without manual intervention make
the application automatable  e consists of
industrializing and automating
repetitive tasks
the solution provided by google cloud
to achieve these objectives of
scalability and automation and the
manager instanz group where is put I have
as its name indicates it is a
grouping of  identical virtual machines
managed by google cloud for
you the few parameters to
configure are the criteria by
which to increase or decrease the number
of instances to adapt to the load as
well as the procedure according to which
a new virtual machine is
added to the group on  is put and
also allows software updates to be applied
to all
member machines of a group while
minimizing downtime
before continuing let's look at the
current architecture of the
fantastic tricolor on google cloud in
which the vms hosting the  front you do
n't have that are created and configure
manually
what would happen for example if we
see a rise  extreme traffic
due to a discount applied to a
very popular product on our website
i don't think they reindeer
claude need to be up at three
in the morning monitoring the load
on the servers  and added
machines to absorb the increase in
load
it is a repetitive task which should
be fully automated in this
scenario a malaise in the stat group
would be perfect for managing the
fountain part suffered from the lamp architecture
we will first  look at how to
configure it to adapt to
load increases
and then how to apply
software updates to all the
instances of the group
before creating the manage insurance group
we must create a temple is
an instance this is a way  to tell
friends I have how to create new
virtual machines in group
this purchase contains information
concerning the type of machine its
operating system and its
configuration  ion network
one last thing to configure and
deactivate external ip addresses of
member instances of a museum as
a security measure to prevent them from being
directly exposed on the internet
it is both a good
security practice but it is also  logical in
our case because only traffic
from the internet goes through the
global load balancers once the temple is
done we can create a friend I'm
ashamed must choose a name and specify
if it is located in a single or  in
several zones of gc pays to
ensure high availability 1 m ise multizone will
distribute the instances through
three zones in the same region like
the load balancers and global this one will
distribute the traffic only towards the
available zones
we then choose the temple is
d  'instance previously created
as our application is a
web application that works in
http protocol
we select auto skelling http with
our targets the 80%
that  means that when the number of
requests per second or rps reaches
this value of 80%
a new instance will be created from
the east temple and added to the group
to absorb the new load we
then configure the maximum and
minimum number of instances in the  group these
are the limit limits between which the
number of virtual machines can
vary this
is a very good way to
manage costs by ensuring never to
exceed a certain threshold
but it also carries a risk if the
maximum value is too low  and that the
load in the mig-21 exceeds the
available capacity this one will not be able to
add new machines to
absorb the additional load in
our case we select 3 for the
minimum and 12 for the maximum since the
group instance manager and multi zone
distributed  on three zones we
also configure the cooling period
which indicates to friends I have
the time interval from which it
can lan  cer the el sheikh the
health check of an instance newly
added to the group
we must ensure that this value is
greater than the time required
to initialize the application
then we configure the el sheikh the
way the mig-29  daughter that the
member virtual machines of the group
are available to absorb traffic
the important Czech dual parameters
are the protocol and the port number
on which the check will be made
the time interval between two
successive checks the timeout
beyond which considered that  'a
check failed
the thresholds in terms of the number of
successive checks passed or
failed from which an instance
is considered to be healthy or
not
let's look at the result in terms
of instance
in some time john marks
three virtual machines which
corresponds  to the three instances created
by our manage instance group
the minimum number that we had
configured pass my  ntaining to the
configuration of the load balancers and the
auto skelling we will create a batch
of balancers h and ups for which the bin
is a service will be the manager in-stat
this group we configure the load balancers
in rps mode requests per second
in order to  that each instance
serve up to 80 requests per second
100% of the time for host parameters
and not soultz we leave the default values be aware
however that you can confi
ure a global load balancers using
a web path is published throu
h the same  global ip address of 2
in peak coming from 2 different kent bats
such as slash api
and slash fountain in the
fountain config section
we start to put a static ip address
the last step is to create some
firewall rules to allow the
Czech she  instances of the fmi I have
a mouth use
predefined source ip address ranges to
access the service pack m from the
loadbalancers and we must  so create
entry firewall rules or a
greece to allow this
address range to access our instances
the time has come to test our
configuration we will use the
command line tool at patxi ab to
generate a peak of  load in a loop
strong from 1 to 1000 we execute at each
iteration a thousand rockets on 100
connections in parallel we notice in
the first part of the test that the manage
instance group contains only three
instances they can absorb the
load generated by advancing in the test
the load increases and we can observe
how the auto skelling comes into play the
mig-21 hear me the number of instances
up to twelve the maximum number once
the test is finished and the load reduced the
number of instances slightly decreased  up to
three the minimum number
now let's talk about automation
let's imagine that a new version of the
linux kernel has just been released it is
optimized for our web server and
includes two patches of  critical security
to deploy this new version
we have to update the
base image from which the
virtual machines of our friend i have are created
with the feature rowling update of manage
instanz group
it becomes very easy the more we
can  make in a controlled way
the rolling update for the mig-21 made
by indicating to this one a new
temple is the instance and the way
to apply the update from the
new temple is
one selects the new temple is one
indicates to  friends I have to involve it on
100% of group member instances and
we select the
proactive update mode the update is immediate or
opportunistic the mig-21 updates each
instance the next time it is
turned off
d  'other parameters to configure his
master gee number of instances added
to the group before applying the
update max la bd ball number of instances
unavailable at a given time
max payne the delay before  apply the
update a quick word
on updates during periods of peak web traffic
they are of course not recommended but if
you have to do so make sure
that the max hurd value is well
above max payne bebel and that the
difference is the number
of instances needed to support
peak traffic
click dawn debt and track
mig-15 and updates on
group instances with minimal
downtime
we've come to the end  from this
episode we saw together how to
use in-stat manades this group
to manage the load auto skelling and
how to automate updates in
a simple and efficient way see
you in the next episodes
to explore together
google cloud technologies
thank you for  your attention and see you soon
[Music]